foreign
[Applause]
s we all have them we all cook with them
we all love how they sound like a
Museum's worth of medieval armor falling
over when you open it
ding dong we get it you don't stack well
who's up first
hey here he is the boss man the Creator
and executive producer of this show hey
but I knew him when he was a frisbee
cake pan why don't you tell us when the
cake is done what's the big secret yeah
tambourine could do your job but with
more Pizzazz but seriously cake pan
you're a true original and we all owe
you our careers
oh well look who it is the Big Man on
Campus the stockpot you live in the
dream stockpot the dream that I'm ever
gonna make soup for 300 people the
stockpot we love you when the roof leaks
or Somebody's gotta puke you never let
us down the only thing more useless than
stockpot is crock pot and his friend the
instapot I didn't realize instant means
take 20 minutes to pressurize and 20
more to cook
it's five pages of safety warnings talk
about pressure but
hey at least you both cook on your own
and you're always good for 20 bucks at
the garage sale good luck to you both
ouch my ears it's the loud mouth of the
kitchen it's teapot take teapot train
whistles called they're angry you stole
their act before you go tooting about
water remember that your job is to make
Leaves wet and hot so somebody else can
have a drink with them
sends my eyelashes it's colander hey
Colin I'd offer you a drink but you
can't hold your liquor hey what's hey it
wasn't hundred holes and is the leading
cause of steam injury you're looking at
him you're not a pot you're a prank show
Colin the get out of here wow that
really is cabinets for us thank you Pops
without you we just have takeout give
yourself a plank thanks for being good
sports see you dinner your metal morons
good night
[Music]
[Applause]